hello my name is Tai kawaii director  actor  welcome to Thor Ragnarok Tychus humor  it's so particular and unique and quirky  all of these tiny little things hanging  washing on electrical cables that's  exactly what we do on it I'm into the  story a day on the set working with tyka  involves high jinks dancing day is just  a big kid we like that the whole time  kind of just cracking up on Steph Steph  later than most light-hearted fun set  I've been on scrapper 142 to 114 tooth  scrapper  look at this world of amazement here  through this door  Oh Australia  it's a Korean Radio Shack so carryin  Walkman the Korean iPod the Korean  Plumbing Supplies justly like Earth  Plumbing Supplies  that is how you make movies  you